turn that great idea you know it's great
i know it's great now we want everyone
to know what's great
into a reality with squarespace they
make it easier than ever to launch your
passion project
if you want to showcase work or sell
products of any kind they have beautiful
templates and the ability to customize
just about anything so you can easily
make a beautiful website all by yourself
but if you get stuck don't worry it
happens to the best of us
squarespace's 24 7 award-winning
customer support
is there to help you out so head to
squarespace.com grace for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain
[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
i'm very
very excited to have michelle muto here
on this episode you might know her as a
comedian
as a host she's got an upcoming netflix
special out called welcome to butopia
she is the host of the netflix social
experiment called the circle she's also
a new mom
she's just an all-around insanely lovely
human being and i had such a wonderful
conversation with her
about starting in journalism at the
florida international university
to now uh making furniture with her
dutch husband
she is into so many things is so busy
and has some really great pieces of
advice and information for you on this
episode of not too deep enjoy
[Music]
wonderful um thank you for being here
i'm so excited
you are even in these wild times
the busiest lady you have so many things
going on
it's so incredible it's so exciting
uh i don't even know where to start
um but i'll start with something that i
completely forgot that you were involved
in because it feels like a thousand
years ago the circle
yes january 1st feels like another
lifetime
for sure it really does also it's very
bizarre i was just
like thinking through that whole concept
of a series that
how you guys kind of predicted the way
we would all be existing with each other
you know i i have to give a shout out to
the production company
studio lambert because it's originally a
show in the uk and they have different
versions of it now
um there's a french version brazilian
and then the american version
and um yeah i'd love me some reality tv
and then also
like with a dollop of social experiment
like sign me up
but who knew that it um would be a sign
of the times
and then right so so covet friendly to
shoot we're gonna
actually get into season two and three
this year
oh nice i was gonna ask if there's more
because i feel like at least for myself
i
took a second to dive in because you
know being in
the internet world i was like uh oh is
this going to make me feel gross about
like the way i've lived my life
but then i immediately being a super fan
of all things reality tv and social
experiment
like obviously ate it up uh when it was
pitched to you or presented to you how
how was it presented did you watch the
uk version first
yeah i mean i read um i read about the
show
and it seemed like not gross but i'm
just like
oh man why are we in a competition um
you know why can we catfish you know and
uh it just sounded crazy yeah
and then i watched it and i said oh my
god this is something that i would love
to be a part of
because you know it's so important
really for people who are not
comfortable on social media
because either they're just not
comfortable they don't know how to
navigate or they're not comfortable with
themselves
this is important for people who are new
to social media
have never been on it and they're like
how do i do it because you have to do it
to work now especially in these times
right um amazing the stories of people
that would catfish you know the fact
that they
have been internet bullied and just want
to be somebody else
really gives a different side to
catfishing that we've never seen before
yeah it's always like they're the enemy
and it's like no we're all just like
beautiful souls trying to get through
the damn day and sometimes the likes
you know sometimes people live in the
lights that is a fact
yeah so um yeah when i watched a couple
of seasons i was like oh my goodness i
have to do this show plus they're like
you get to be your sassy self i said
oh that's so good yes melissa was just
saying before you got on that she
thought that you weren't utilized to
your full potential on that show and
that we could do with more obviously
oh i love it thank you but
the i think it's so wonderful because
yeah it is something that's usually
kind of looked at in a like a could be
looking a gross or like shameful lens
and i feel like
it gave a chance to handle it more
gently and to like
allow people to showcase their
complexities in a way that we just write
off so quickly
yes and the fact that um the casting was
so beautifully done
because if you're really going to
showcase the diversity of america
you know it's sort of like the voice
right where it's young
and old it's not just like 18 to 24. you
know
it's it's young people that haven't been
on the internet like shoe bomb
um it is ed from pennsylvania who has
his mom with him because a lot of people
check in with their moms there's nothing
wrong with that
yeah so yeah i mean i i have a friend
who asks her mom to reread every
email she sends because she's a bit
fiery
okay
i want to be like she's a [ __ ]
built-in pr woman yeah it's great look
her mom married it and now she has a kid
look i don't need to get into other
people's history
okay but that's also
the crazy thing is like how big the
circle was that's just like a small
dot on the whole like orchestra of
things that you have going on
this year small circle it's a small
circle i'm so excited that there's more
of it
that's great i'm very because my in
watching it my biggest like question
when it was done was
oh man how are people going to approach
this in upcoming seasons now that
there's a little bit of a blueprint for
some people i know i know that's the
thing right everyone has a plan when
they go in but i will say
um you never know how people
are going to react to your picture your
profile picture
says a lot you know whether you know it
or not
and um playing the circle is sort of
like doing stand-up comedy where you can
be prepared
but what you're once you're in there you
know you just gotta roll with the
punches you really never know
totally well um i wanna know a little
bit more about
your start in stand-up because i know
that you
originally went to school thinking about
journalism
yeah and you went to the florida
international
university i sure did okay
what did how international was that you
know
nobody spoke english honey it was so
international
wow that's where you go when you can't
get into the university of miami i went
to florida international university
and people will be like damn michelle
your english is so good i'm like i'm so
sorry
i am the american i'm sorry
um but it was a beautiful ass place to
go to school you know i mean
the dominican guys playing baseball
um i didn't even know what j-pop and
k-pop was
wow yeah it was just it was an awesome
place to go to school and i always
wanted to be
a reporter like i just like um
sort of watching a story and then
recapping that's that's my jam
exactly exactly and i was in this tv
production class with um
and this professor was asking us you
know what we want to do people want to
be directors and um screenwriters and i
said i want to be a reporter
and he said in front of the whole class
i'll never forget this um he said well
you're just simply too fat to be on
camera
and um i didn't even
question him because you know i was
brought up to not question authority to
respect
my elders especially my teachers and um
and to be honest
i didn't see anyone that looked like me
on tv either so i was like
oh okay i guess he's right and um now i
could just like
flip a table like a jersey housewife how
dare you tell a kid what they can and
cannot [ __ ] do we should only be
lifting them up but
yeah yeah yeah i really want him to be
watching all my stuff on netflix but
he's probably dead
the point is you know i'm um
i uh i like to call myself like a slow
simmer
um you know it took me a while
to really believe in myself um because i
sort of always waited for people's
permission to
do stuff and um i actually kept getting
that note that she's uh
really funny and she could write for us
but she's just simply
too big to be on camera and so that's
something i actually heard from
an ep an executive producer
not elvis presley and so because that
guy
probably did what i feel like um can
someone give him a mirror for a second
oh too soon
all those banana and peanut butter jelly
peanut butter jelly peanut butter banana
sandwiches i'm fine english is my first
language i can't be
hard so um yeah i just worked in
production so i was like okay
cool i still want to be creative i still
want to be part of the tv process
and local news was just sort of
something i fell into
i went to wsbn fox affiliate in miami
now
to get an internship but they were
hiring and all of a sudden i was just
working as a news editor and uh i liked
it i like the fast pace
of it i love that news is um you feel
like you're helping
you know like you have a part in
something sure
you know the news will always happen so
you always have a job
and then when i graduated i started
working at wnbc which is the local nbc
um station in new york city in 2001.
so yeah that's kind of like how i got
into it but there was always this little
part of me where i was just like
so tired of editing these basic [ __ ]
to look good
you know i'm so tired of giving you my
zhu zhu and you're
[ __ ] up because you can wear a crop
top
and so i mean this is a moment to be
had honey yeah a few things with sex
scenes
uh really okay i want to find out how
you prep for that
um but that i mean it must have given
you such
an interesting perspective on
one like as a comedian you're making
observations about people
and the world constantly and to come
from news that just kind of makes sense
that that would be a little bit of an
evolution
for you to be able to have more freedom
and use your voice and your juju and not
give it to anyone else to take advantage
of in any way
was there was there like a moment that
you kind of like pivoted or was there
like kind of over time you just slowly
found yourself
leaning towards a comedy world i was
never leaning towards comedy people were
leaning towards comedy
for me i always had co-workers they were
just like you're so funny you should do
stand-up and i'm like i've been to shows
they're all sweaty they're all sad
they're all [ __ ] broke i don't like
you bro
i like my lights on i don't like [ __ ]
jokes i don't like porn jokes these
[ __ ] seem sad
plus there was no women so again i
didn't feel seen so i was like i don't
even know what you guys are talking
about because
there's people that do the stand up and
then there's like wanda sykes or
margaret cho and i'm like
yeah rosie o'donnell like i haven't been
doing this since i was 18. so i don't
know how to do that
and so yeah i mean i would definitely
tell stories
um people liked the stories i would
write emails about
like roommate that had an all-white cat
named cocaine and she'd always put like
olive oil on her face
and her hair and all her doorknobs were
like so [ __ ] slippery i'm like girl
you gotta get your favorite [ __ ]
together
but people are like this is so funny you
know you should do it in sting
and i'm like yeah but i mean
so i was already thinking about it and i
even took a class to like figure out
what a joke was and i was like i don't
know that this is for me
and then um and then
9 11 happened and i was working and i
worked through it and
um and we i mean it's pretty much all i
did for
like the next four years but that week
was so [ __ ] bananas because
you know you're just sitting in this
dark
5x5 edit bay with no windows and a
writer who just
starts crying or you start crying and
news is coming in and
you have to like somehow edit around um
gruesome [ __ ] yeah and um
yeah i remember our news director was
just like well we're gonna offer therapy
to everybody if you guys want it
and i was like no i'm gonna i think i'm
just gonna like try stand up again
like just try it like yeah since i
already took a class i'm going to see
what this is
and so september 14th 2001 was the first
time i did stand up
wow and i've been doing it ever since
wow i mean yeah so you've been
using comedy to process major world
tragedies
for a while yes uh
that's fascinating and also okay
in terms of you going and studying and
like
you're a storyteller now you have a book
coming out called survival of the
thickest
and is yeah these are
short stories from you
yeah yeah is okay these are plus-size
stories in a small-minded world
i love it i love it i love it i love it
i love it
is there because on top of that i mean
you have so much going on you're welcome
to be utopia which is your first
uh special coming out at the end of
september
how do you choose what goes into a book
versus what you use for stage
i don't know i feel like i feel like
that material chooses itself
if that makes sense because you know
some of the stuff i write about that is
um
personal and sincere and traumatic will
definitely go on the book
um also growing up and you know stories
from my childhood i mean
some are really great for stage or even
storytelling on stage but
some just need to live in print and so
it's been a very interesting process
even editing the book so i'm like
ah i put that on stage i didn't remember
saying that
because it really is just me i mean i
think people think i'm out here writing
jokes and like for the most part yes i'm
formulating stuff but like
this is just you know it is she is who
she is and so
it's been really fun and crazy
and um fulfilling and draining
um putting yourself out there and you
know for a good minute i would just like
give myself like hot liquid diarrhea
just thinking about
this book coming out because like when
you do like a sex storytelling
show you're in a dark room no one can
take video or pictures
and it's just like you know it's like
therapy it just goes away and you feel
better
like after you say it but now with the
book it is
important so people are gonna
no uh-huh and people are gonna have a
much more intimate experience with a
book versus you like on stage that they
see and then it the
story goes into the ether somewhere this
is gonna be like a tangible thing that
people can spend time with
uh is there i think the the cool
thing about you too is that you live so
authentically out loud you're very much
yourself and you share a lot of like
really personal things
very publicly is that
can people expect that from the book as
well
oh for sure you know i didn't
i didn't go into stand-up or into
hosting or whatever
to say i'm gonna put all my business out
there
uh because i don't know how to shut up
that's not who she is
there is some business that people don't
know of course i can't talk about
everything even though i'd love to
but you know um after
doing a podcast and doing other people's
podcasts even storytelling shows i
realized
um the feedback was just different than
i had a [ __ ] day and you made me laugh
the feedback was like
i feel less alone um a doctor did that
to me too
or i i you know a nurse treated me like
this as well
and so you know
if i can somehow make people feel less
alone
that is way more important than getting
a laugh it's the only thing i want to
[ __ ] do
and you know um and if i could do that
through
sharing my stories that's that's what
i'm gonna [ __ ] do because
you know we all have a gift and it's
like if we're not using it then what the
[ __ ] are you doing good you know what
you're good at
do it i think that's so
powerful and i think people think that's
like common knowledge so they kind of
disregard
that advice sometimes but i think it's
so important to like really remind
people of that
especially you saying that when you went
to college you didn't see people like
you doing the things that you wanted to
do so to be able to now be that person
for a younger girl that didn't
necessarily see herself
i think is so important and so exciting
um so not only are you doing all this
stuff but you also have babies
that you've added to your life because
you can't stop being busy it turns out
oh my god what is that
i know um this is so wild so what has
been
it has there been i mean i'm sure it's
been this incredible crazy
whirlwind ride for you has there been
like
the most surprising thing have you
learned about yourself obviously
in any ways that you didn't expect oh my
god
i um i
not to sound like an [ __ ] but i
didn't really realize
how much of a team my husband and i are
because you know we've gotten lost and
found our way
like on vacation we've put together ikea
furniture
yeah we haven't started a furniture
store together like we've done [ __ ]
together
but to be in this process of five years
and four miscarriages
him driving me to every doctor's
appointment him giving me all the shots
unless i'm on the road and then he's on
the facetime walking me through the
shots
for him picking me up off the bathroom
floor
because i'm in pain or i am just utterly
just
you know done just done with the day
just done with this process for him to
still
sort of you know be this quiet
gentle giant who's like just very strong
in all of it
is you know when people are like it
brought us closer together i just want
to be like
did it but sometimes it [ __ ] do
and um yeah when you least expect it so
i feel like
i didn't know how strong we were that's
amazing i also didn't know how
attractive we were
you know i'm just saying like these kids
look good i see other kids i'm just like
i don't know
they don't have hair yet at a year and a
half our kids are just like
uniqlo red
even when they were born i was just like
everybody looks so inbred
even the nurses just like they these
these babies are handsome
i know [ __ ] so like i'm very excited
because
guess they're good people yes sure but
they're also like
so cute like i cannot you know
mix prints give it to me goodbye
oh that's wonderful and i think that's
something that new parents
probably overlook and don't think about
till they actually see the child
face to face that like oh right yeah
you've got a little 18
you gotta change that diaper
you and your husband also celebrated 10
years together
yes congratulations 10 years of marriage
12 years together out of a one-night
stand you guys
open your legs to love and your heart
and your mind
be careful you're too cute for bacteria
get tested did you know they found covet
and semen don't swallow that [ __ ] oh i
am just saying
this is i mean you're a wheelhouse of
information and education
and it's it is
everyone fires they're like shut up
oh that's so great we're so lonely so
you and your husband met
through a one-night stand yes
okay and then what was the situation
after that led to
seeing each other again it was really
him in the follow up because i was like
i don't even know how to say your name
bro i don't even know where amsterdam is
really
so so nice to meet you thank you for not
being an [ __ ]
thank you for taking your shoes off when
you came in bye
and so he he sent me a picture like
three days later and he was like put
this on your website was a subject and
it was like a picture
he took of us like in bed just like
hugging but my boob was hanging out
and i was like oh i can't put that on my
website because my boobs hanging out
and then he's a photographer so he
photoshopped my boob out and put a
mustache on me
i was like wow [ __ ] funny so
it was just like a weird he totally
dated me
um over um the internet
he wooed me um in a way where
i had dates lined up in new york where
i'm like i don't feel like going
to this date and pretending that this
person's interesting i
would rather have a glass of wine at
home and talk to this dutch dude
and um every morning when i would wake
up he'd send me email and the subject
would be
song of the day and he would just like
pick a song for me to listen to i'm just
like
wow who are you wow
good he's breaking all the molds
jeez i know uh
well now you guys are obviously a
wonderful
unit is there any sort of like
secret code of how much of your personal
life you're allowed to share
does he have like a boundary put in
place for that he does and i didn't even
know what he did for like five years in
and i'm like i just decided to ask him
he didn't even say anything else i could
say anything you know
he said you know what i really don't
like when you
um make me stand up at your shows and
have people clap for my dick
i thought you lost it you were waving
like the [ __ ] queen
okay there are certain things and then
my mom was like you know what i don't
like it when you make me sit up and have
people clap for my cities
i thought we were here i thought we were
here
i was celebrating you oh god i was
celebrating
it's always good to communicate on those
on those levels
and figure out where to go from there uh
the more you know
the more you know okay we're gonna take
a quick break when we get back i have a
million more questions for you so we'll
be right back with more not too deep
[Music]
hey you with that dream it's time to
turn it into a reality with guess who
none other than squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project
and we all i'm sure have some sort of
project
swirling around in our brains do you
want to start a new business showcase
your work publish content sell products
or more
squarespace is the tool for you they
have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers you can customize
just about anything with a few
clicks so you all by yourself can easily
make a beautiful website
they also have power ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online
and analytics that help you grow your
site in real time
and everything is optimized for mobile
right out of the box so there's nothing
to patch
or upgrade ever buying domains is simple
and if it's not so simple to you you can
get all the help you need
with their 24 7 award-winning customer
support
they empower millions of people from
designers to lawyers
artists to gamers even restaurants and
gyms to turn great ideas into something
real
so head to squarespace.com grace for a
free trial
and when you're ready to launch at your
leisure use the offer code grace to save
10 of your first purchase of a website
or domain
that's squarespace.com grace offer code
grace
okay we are back with michelle
now uh what
is it like you have your first stand-up
special coming out the end of september
you must be very excited but it must
also be this weird thing because you
shoot it already and what's this time
like
before it comes out this in between
um this limbo yeah it's
um it's wild but it also is
really just so necessary
and fun to look forward to something i'm
thirsty for it i
watched a special you know to make edits
and i was like god i remember this just
a fun time i forgot a lot of the jokes
because it does feel like another life
and
i picked the date march 1st to film
because
that was my grandma's birthday and wow
she lived in jamaica
um and so we'd always go to jamaica for
her birthday and it was always like this
fun time in the winter
and so when i saw that data i was like
maybe it's louise
i see you girl um thank you boo and um
i'm so glad i picked that date because
any day after that
would it would have gotten shut down
like i really feel for those comedians
who have been
working on their set honing their hour
only for it to be like
i don't know on pause for the cause but
it i wanted the special to feel like a
night out in new york and now it feels
like
the last night out in new york yeah it's
gonna feel
i mean watching it's gonna be so
exciting because i think it's gonna give
people a taste of like
what was and that what might be able to
come back in the future
right i'm like high-fiving strangers
there's drag queens i motorboat like
just some stranger
like i miss motorboating strangers you
know
well how did you um yeah truly one of
the
greatest activities that we're all
missing out on
uh what was the prep like because i've
talked to other comedians about it and i
don't do stand-up and i have such
respect for people that do because it is
terrifying to me but what was your prep
like in getting this together
um i feel like i was working on material
for a while but when the babies were
born
it really feel it really felt like a
home aha moment where i was just like
oh i've been waiting to get to the other
side of this mountain
so i've just been waiting the for the
the right to earn tired mom jokes yeah
yeah
here we are and uh paige hurwitz and
wanda sykes produced it
and they are just an amazing um
duo that um you know because wanda has
been
doing stand-up forever and have so many
specials they
they know what people will react to they
know what stand-ups want to do in their
first special
and they sort of just were like these
wonderful producers
slash therapists wow cool
yeah so it was really fun working with
them i just loved the experience and um
i mean we had drag queens opening and
jessica kirsten did um
warm up i keep hitting my desk which is
just
it's laundry day it's also laundry day
and podcasting day so here we are
i love it yeah you can't stop being
relatable
i love it
[Laughter]
that's so but it's also nice to know
that you're in good hands and to know
that like you can trust the opinions of
the people that are helping you put this
together and really feel like you're
guided correctly because i feel like
this is such a special thing for
stand-ups and their first one i feel
like it's almost
i mean i don't know either of these
experiences but like having a baby
almost
it no it really is and um they
you know if you are um not just a female
stand-up but if you want to do anything
right um and
you feel like you have to go to these
four people these four guys because
those are the people everyone goes to
and that's
they're supposed to be the the it people
and they like are the
the gatekeepers like no that's not so
like there's
um real power in going somewhere where
you're celebrated and not tolerated
and people hear you and what i loved
about paige and wanda
is um they understand how specials work
they understand how netflix specials
work they did tiffany haddishes and
fortune teamsters
and um you know the fact that
most people don't think women are funny
the fact that people will
um tune out within the first 10 minutes
all these things they're just like we
have to think about these things and so
it was so nice to work with people that
have your back and
you know for anyone who is trying to get
into something whether it's
screenwriting
or book writing or you know
a good old makeup artist i don't know
what you're trying to get into but there
is
real power in working with people
you know like a forest bias situation
yeah that makes so much sense uh it
makes you feel just like
i'm sure that your final product you
feel that much more sound
about and that much more like
enthusiastic about
yeah speaking of working with people
that
know how to challenge gatekeepers you
worked on
are you a mall cop cause you got a
segway honey big time
big time big time it's all i got these
days
um you're in work it the new
netflix movie that's uh
dancing and there's a lot of um you know
new media internet kids
kind of in that movie uh
did you learn anything from them about
social media
about digital world at all
oh my goodness i did i feel like less is
more
why am i overthinking something and have
to write a post i can just like write a
sentence that is funny and funny
and just like leave it like i'm out here
doing the most
did i conjugate this verb properly
nobody cares
also also there's nothing wrong with
like really like
sort of appreciating your filters you
know what i mean
um but what i loved about working on
this movie i mean sabrina carpenter
and just everybody you know they're so
much younger than me
but they also have been in the business
for
ever and so no matter if they're like
you know 18 or 58 everybody was sort of
like on the same page when it came to
the business and making executive
decisions because sabrina also ep'd it
and i was like damn this is boss
yeah yeah yeah yeah i know that's the
wow
that's the fun and intimidating thing
about successful like digital
uh content creators is that they the
really
successful ones are incredibly
intelligent
super hard working and like really
understand the business side of it and
it's
intimidating in a way but very cool
yeah i mean it's it's very cool like a
master class but at a lunch table
i'm sure the you said you love reality
tv
uh have you gotten into anything lately
what do you
what are you watching if you ever have
time because i feel like your hours must
be stacked
hours are stacked i have between eight
and nine pm which is my me time and
sometimes
i just stare at a wall but for the most
part i love
i love the real housewives of new york
although it is a little aggressive and
they just fired dorinda because she's
drunk all the time and i feel sad about
that but also you can't be jerking like
that
yeah i know i'm super into them and i
stopped watching this season because it
just got a little
repetitive and a little like uh hopeless
i felt like i couldn't root one
exactly i'm like how are you making
ramona look like some
cook yeah i know oh god i don't feel bad
saying that but yeah um real housewives
of beverly hills
watching that um yes come out with your
prosecco line anytime you feel like it
a fashion line like who are these people
just work those ponytails before they
work you i've never seen people
get four hours of glam just to fight at
a dinner table i'm like
this is the worst thanksgiving dinner
i've ever been to in another country
i know out here so you can fight a
different time zone i love it now i just
want
a montage of over the years when they
want to get out of their conversations
of them just going bravo bravo bravo
over and over again oh my god who knew
but they're also in italy so i'm like
bravo
yeah that was very confusing
i didn't even think about that yeah 90
day fiance that is my
[ __ ] everything the first to last my
everything i mean also my husband and i
were sort of like on that visa but we
were just like
no we definitely want to get married so
we love the hot mess
that is michael and angela angela like
getting married in nigeria because she's
always done
her bras of bodega it's there's probably
a metal detector in there
i don't know oh my god who doesn't enjoy
watching a white south african dude just
like not a piece of meat and yelled his
wife in front of his family this is
amazing this is why the government gives
us 90 days to decide how sad we're going
to [ __ ] be
awesome it's insane and i'm just like
david you spent over 500 000
trying to talk to a ukrainian woman you
could just like go to queens what the
[ __ ] is
that i know there is oh i mean this is
why i feel like the circle handled this
a little bit
better but i i do i have like my
my boyfriend has gotten into reality tv
because i'm such a reality tv junkie
but 90 day fiance is the one that he
kind of draws the line because he's like
that's a little too
real and sad at moments that i can't oh
no it's so good
big ed taking a shower in the
philippines with a rat that's not
cancer are you serious i
just want to pour cold water on ed's
titties that
is everything what your boyfriend needs
to get his life
is so much better all of it i know
that's better
after all of the giving her toothbrush
and toothpaste and just be like because
your breath is
all of the yes she's sleeping by an
albino rat who gives a [ __ ] about her
breasts go save her egg
bring her imprisoned america what's
wrong with you um
but i watch like more stuff too like
indian matchmaking
or love on the spectrum feel good stuff
yes yes yes yes we just finished love on
the spectrum and uh i want more of it
immediately it was my goodness
and so heartwarming so valuable because
what a beautiful question to say okay
now they've graduated school
what next yeah i never think like that
exactly um is there a reality show
that you would want to be on other than
the circle
no no yeah i feel like too
i'm feeling i'm strictly an observer i
don't want to be in this yes
why it brings me joy who told you that
no no nobody nothing i would love to be
like
a judge in america's got talent because
i'd be like everyone
goes through to the live round maybe
like michelle scott you can't
keep doing that
oh that's so good um well okay
now that you've come uh you you started
out in the news world
it do you where do you get your news
from
these days if you check in
the void got it okay i know i'm like is
it an apple or a banana i mean
i kind of do everything i still do i
still do news the way i did it back then
where i'm sort of you know
um chiming into all of it the
conservative deliberate all the things
to see what people are saying
um also i've never read so much
telegraph which is a
dutch outlet so i think it's really
interesting to see what the bbc
is saying and then also other places
that have coveted under control
that have a different political system
with more than two parties
you know uh the thing about i don't want
to say the thing about holland is so
nice but it really is
um every country has their thing but
it's really beautiful in holland that at
least they have like
12 political parties so you could be gay
but
fiscally conservative and and feel
seen you know what i mean like it isn't
just like this or that and so
this has just been a crazy ass time i
mean
my husband's bald but he's growing his
hair and i'm losing my hair
we are a mess we are just like castaway
but just gaining weight instead of
losing but we've learned how to fish
it is something there you go i mean
you're working on your survival skills
so in case in case whatever's going to
happen i think that's smart i haven't
thought about that of
looking at the more international news
outlets to see how they're covering and
reporting on everything
where that's how much of a bubble we're
in i know
i know but even canadian news like
especially what are people saying about
us
it is fascinating and they have
different facts that we don't have
yeah yeah yeah i mean that is a good way
to fact check
i haven't thought about that now i have
some work to do this afternoon thank you
for
uh informing me um okay we're gonna take
one last break when we get back i have a
bunch of twitter questions for you that
are all very wonderful
so we'll be right back with more not too
deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say
two things a big thank you for listening
to the podcast
uh if you're a regular listener if this
is your first time listening welcome and
thank you
and uh second thing if you are enjoying
yourself here
in this not too deep world we've built
and you'd like to leave us a review that
would be
so wonderful if you can go to the itunes
store the app store and leave us a
lovely little
review comment how are you feeling good
bad otherwise maybe just good or
otherwise would be appreciated
other than that enjoy the podcast
okay i do want to ask you about first
wives club this is so exciting
um you must be i mean among all the
other great wonderful things that are
going on
for you uh how how did you hear
the news like how did this how'd you
find out that you were gonna be part of
this and that this was happening
oh man this is so crazy um i was
actually in vancouver filming
always be my maybe when i got the
audition and
i kind of didn't take it seriously
because i'm like this is definitely
going to be an offer to someone
famous and i think as you know
just like struggling actors you
overshoot you know
tessa thompson ain't busy
you know and when i read that jill scott
was attached i was like that's awesome
but there's no way they're gonna
hire you know um two actresses that
aren't a size eight so i just sort of
like
told and this is the thing i tell people
don't tell yourself no before other
people tell you now
and i was like i guess i'll do this you
know because i'm in vancouver what else
am i doing you know what i mean just
breathing their good air and having it
edible looking at whales
sure and so
um there's also this time where um
i was like coming down from the ivf
train but i was still
very emotional because the hormones were
all up in the system
and so for a lot of auditions i would
just like end up crying at the end
but like definitely through my funny
lines and they're like this is wild what
a
great button i'm like thank you and so
for the audition um there was a scene
where she sort of
tells her friends that she's breaking up
with her childhood sweetheart because
he's cheated on her
and i've been cheated on before like in
high school and in college
but you know i just remember what that
hurt was like when
someone that you um thought you knew
is not that person at all and you have
to figure out how to
put your life together yeah which sounds
crazy but
it is a shock and so
i don't know i was by myself coming down
the ivf train
real tapped in and gave them an audition
that they were just like
is she okay
yeah and that's how you know you nailed
it too is when they
love it but they're also a little
concerned for your mental health
that was good she's okay right right
okay cool
uh wow wow wow yeah so
that must have been wild for you emo
like what an emotional roller coaster
it really was um also we were in the
process of
you know working with our surrogate and
so i just felt like
so out of control for so many things
that i was like okay i'm just gonna work
my ass off because i have control of
that
yeah um and so it was really fun to have
something to look forward to
that's awesome i'm so excited i mean i
add it to the list of amazing things
that you're
up to it's very cool um okay okay i'm
gonna get into twitter questions before
i do i'm gonna ask you
the two questions ask every single guest
that's on the podcast
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most like to throw cold spaghetti at
oh my goodness anthony bourdain
wow okay i don't know if we've had that
for an answer
any particular reason why i just think
he'd get a kick out of it
yeah i think he'd eat it and talk about
it yeah yeah
yeah i mean i think it'd be fun actually
i think that'd be a great
okay the other question i ask every
guest is to tell us your worst
pant [ __ ] story or um like a close
call
but you can only use three words or
small phrases
so for example mine is college jogging
front lawn
[Music]
catholic catholic school
jello front seat okay
wow i like that it was a religious
experience
yes it was biblical yeah oh boy okay no
follow-up questions to that
uh let's get into these welcome
let's get into these twitter questions
someone says
um i'm buying my first apartment
adulting at its finest
and it's made me wonder what is
something you thought you would do with
your own place when you were a kid
that now seems weird
um gosh i don't know
i've always been like an old soul
i feel like i'm like a little big titty
benjamin button now
you know what i mean yeah yeah so i i
don't know how to answer that you know
i've always wanted more than one
bathroom because i feel like that's a
true sign of success
[Music]
uh with mm-hmm a hundred percent a
hundred percent do you have you and your
husband cultivated like a
hybrid design aesthetic for your home
yeah he's definitely more mid-century
modern and i'm more
boho ship yeah um so it's really nice i
mean either way it's so nice not having
to go to pier 1 imports because i'm not
22 anymore nobody needs that many
elephants in their house
or delta let's be honest we also
own a furniture business together called
vandermost modern evandermostwater.com
yeah so so okay this is uh
this is still happening your furniture
business it is
we're actually doing better than ever
which is great because i'm realizing
that people
are home and they have to like turn one
space into eight different functions but
also
you know um his belief which i love
and believe in now and want to teach our
kids is that you have to buy things that
um are well made you know um
i think we're just like a new now next
sort of um culture
and it's really important to buy things
that are well made that will appreciate
so
you know you have your money make some
money bo yeah your money makes money you
deserve
a honey that's great advice especially
because
i feel like so many people don't like
graduate from a dorm
aesthetic in their design because
there's not many
options to do so i am not spreading my
legs in my 20s or 30s for a man who has
like text on a poster
frame get out um okay this is a very
funny tweet someone says
ask her uh ask her how i saw her outside
a party supply store in brooklyn two
summers ago
i'm sure she remembers me i was in an
uber yelling out the window is that
michelle bouteau
i don't remember that but that seems
that just seems so sweet
very sweet do you have do people mistake
you
for other people ever oh my god
are you serious yes what's what do you
get
anyone from raven simone to kim cole's
to their bank teller
to their cousin [ __ ] you don't know
we're not related like
how many cousins do you have [ __ ] it's
really crazy or
they like know me but don't know from
you look familiar yeah [ __ ]
i'm on tv you think i'm nicole
byer really since 2012
i met an executive one time at a meeting
just the one time
and he was like love your work i nailed
it i said that's the other one [ __ ]
and you really gotta get into the gut we
look nothing alike oh my god just like
a big [ __ ] that just loves herself
you're like they're all the same
oh oh god i hope they were
horribly embarrassed uh
someone's to know which horror movie
stereotype would you be
and and when in the order would you die
if at
all oh my god so i've always wanted to
do a horror movie because
i am so jumpy and scared all the time
that it could look
real um every time
and um i would definitely be
the i'm so scared that but i'm also so
flexible nobody would think that i could
like jump that high or fit into that bed
so i'm definitely liam neeson's daughter
in this scenario where the [ __ ] is
gonna survive and i'm gonna come black
for you [ __ ]
oh i love that i feel like that is a
film that could happen um
someone wants some netflix hey
someone wants to know how many days of
work was the circle
oh god what are you my accountant
yeah right um
it's a really well oiled machine so um
they film i watch uh i do
some voice over we have yeah do you
do you get to watch like raw footage
and see what's going on yeah but i
prefer to watch edited
because that just feels like i'm like
watching them
yeah yeah yeah
but now i know what you like uh yeah
well it's like that's why i can't get
into
the big brother show that's the one that
has never really appealed to me because
it feels
too weird lines of intimacy as like an
audience member
for me yeah like i don't need to see you
pick your wedgie like it's fine
yeah trying to egg and picking a wedgie
it's like goodbye
uh someone wants to know do you prefer
making movies or doing stand-up
oh my god i prefer all of it all of it
all the time
i love connecting with people i love
looking cute i love wearing a kitten
heel
and i love making money is there a
creative project or like a genre of
entertainment that you haven't worked in
yet that you want to
like theater musicals like
[ __ ] like that yeah i just told my agent
like
probably it was it last year or this
year what a spacer time
a construct i i said i would love to do
theater but now i don't know about that
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah is there uh
is there like a dream role or project
that like you
have always wanted to do that hasn't uh
happened yet or you're just
you're accomplishing all your dreams i
am
i have some realistic ass goals
which in turn makes everything seem
amazing
um you know i would love to create
content as well
i mean you know by that i mean write a
movie
you know be the bride not the bridesmaid
type [ __ ] that'd be amazing
but i also feel like um that'll happen
you know that'll happen just can we just
go to the store without they were gonna
die first
i know okay here's the last question
before we wrap up
um someone's to know uh have you learned
anything in quarantine good or bad
yeah good god i mean not only
are you quarantining you're quarantining
with your
children now while having all of these
projects to promote going on
in a world where you can't like
physically go out and do the normal
promotions for it so it must be wild for
you
it is wild i'm i definitely like to be
a glass half full kind of [ __ ] so at
least i
get to be home with them and see them
you know um not just grow but make that
face and never made do that thing
hug each other you know eat with a fork
and then i can go
promote whatever i need to promote and
still be home and not do all the travel
i mean i miss
seeing people but in terms of learning
stuff about myself it's like
you know i i've always been um
i've always been sensitive but um
i just never i i always love a good cry
but i i have cried every day i have
cried
every day there is um so much death and
so much
fighting and so much violence and so
much um
just evil [ __ ] going on that i really
did not feel like
i knew kobu would be bad but i didn't
know it would turn into
um a horror movie um and i live
close to heart island which is an island
in new york where um
the government owns it and basically
it's a mass burial site for people
who have died alone wow so like jane and
john
um aids victims industry fires
in the 20s and so there's been a lot of
people
that they've been burying as of late and
it's really so shocking and sad to see
that refrigerated truck
come and do whatever they have to do but
it's such a beautiful island that it
feels like wow
how [ __ ] sad and [ __ ] up as these
people die by themselves but
how beautiful that they get to be buried
all together
you know for eternity on this beautiful
place and so i'm constantly trying to
find
the good in what the [ __ ] it all means
and
um you know i am yeah i have to tag team
with my husband to take a [ __ ] and to do
stuff because
you know it's like we're in a dryer of
like baby limbs we're like
and then you know i look in there i look
at their pictures
and i'm like [ __ ] this is i this is my
responsibility to the universe to raise
dope as human beings that will not you
know
tear the world down yeah girl bye i
don't even know where the [ __ ] she went
that was my dominance
i think that's wonderful because i i
think
like i said earlier you have such a
beautiful ability to live out loud very
authentically and it doesn't feel like
you put on
a persona that is not true to you
and like you said earlier stepping into
your gift and realizing that you have a
power and being able to give that to the
world
even in these times where people i think
need it more than ever
uh is is like a superpower in and of
itself
because you're handling the world and
also being able to give this
gift that you've worked really hard and
diligently on to people
and i think it means even more right now
and the fact that you're
being real and raw and honest is just
even
i think helping people feel not alone
you know that circle thing
yeah i think that's really beautiful i'm
so excited that
you're like [ __ ] hustling and making
cool [ __ ] and like
really being such a wonderful
but for lack of a better word like role
model for young women and boys
oh my god it's very cool it's very very
cool and it's also very inspiring
to myself and i'm sure so many other
people um
before we wrap up completely usually
when we do this podcast in person
we have a personalized fortune cookie
that we give our guest
as a gift for making time for us but
because we're doing it digitally we have
a virtual fortune cookie for you
that i believe melissa has emailed to
you
what
surprise you guys
i feel like i just got a rose
someone may or may have not pre-ordered
your book survival the thickest assuming
at least one chapter was on dick girth
outlook not good whoa
unfortunately how did you know siri
uh oh man talk about growing into your
worth
right right uh this has been really
lovely thank you for making time
i know that you're super super busy uh
where can people find
everything that you're up to where can
they pre-order the book and see the
special if they don't already know
oh my god get your life together if they
follow you they know how the internet
works who gives a [ __ ]
eau [ __ ] yes hell yes please go check
out everything she's up to
it is so exciting i can't wait to see
what the
the next year brings for you because
onwards and upwards
oh my god hopefully it is a mask-free
journey
you know let's see we'll see thank you
again michelle this was lovely
and we'll see you guys on another
episode of not too deep goodbye
bye too deep too deep
too deep deep not too deep with christ
not too deep as a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen lani eunis post
production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music